President Trump and governors across
America urged citizens to stay in for
months the economy continues to melt
down and the media continue to meditate
on the evils of president Trump's press
conferences of all things I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity should
not be public protect yourself and
express it VPN calm / man that's
expressvpn dot-com / Ben well if it
seems like I'm a little bit flustered
this morning this is what it's like
having children in a small space during
a pandemic where everybody's locked
inside I think everybody is feeling me
right now who has kids but even if you
don't have kids look this is a rough
time for the country - rough time for
all of us and people making light of it
like well you know it's not like World
War two wait that's true it's not like
World War two and honestly that is one
of the difficulties that during World
War two
the threat the external threat was
pretty obvious because there were bombs
falling from the sky on buildings and
you could join the military you could go
fight back against a material enemy it's
in in some ways more psychologically
difficult probably to be stuck inside
when there's so much uncertainty about
if I walk outside am I just going to die
from a thing that is in the air um that
doesn't mean that it's tougher than then
the sacrifices made during World War two
obviously people were literally being
killed on beaches in World War two but
psychologically for the average citizen
who stayed at home during World War two
this I've talked some old people who
remember World War two this is really
rough this is this is a rough time and
being told that we are supposed to
remain in our homes and shelter in place
for an indefinite period of time without
even the ability to really sacrifice on
behalf of the country without the
ability to take active measures on
behalf of the country is you know that's
that's a difficult thing and I think
that we're all you know trying to muddle
our way through now thank God we have
the accoutrements of modern life to make
that a lot easier thank God you know
we're not in the business of rationing
here in the United States but I think it
is fair to say it it's funny sometimes
there's somebody complaining about a
minor health problem in somebody said
well you know there are people starving
in Asia and I always thought that such a
dumb response like that that has not
actually alleviated the person suffering
in the here-and-now
it's just comparing it to something
that's much worse it is true their
situations in human life had been a lot
worse it is also true a lot of people
are suffering right now
particularly an economic side a lot of
people are suffering on the
psychological side and to make light of
that would be to be foolish and that of
course is putting aside all of the
incredible human suffering that is going
on by the people in the hospitals the
medical professionals who are trying to
work through this thing and now being
overwhelmed in certain areas of the
country and obviously the people who are
suffering from kovat 19 okay with all of
that said you know we're all gonna try
and get through this together we will
get through this together because there
will be an end date there will be a time
when we all go back out it's gonna take
a while before we get back to life as
normal I think I was think about this
last night I think it's gonna be at
least a year before people are going out
to to mass events before Disneyland
reopens before theaters reopen before
people start going to basketball and
baseball and football games I would be
shocked if the entire the entirety of
the NFL and NBA and and MLB seasons are
not canceled from here on out simply
because in order for people to go out on
mass and feel safe there's gonna have to
be vaccine developed the soonest that
would happen is probably the beginning
of the next year so it's hard for me to
believe that
I think weddings are gonna be downscaled
I think that that big events are gonna
be postponed it's gonna be a rough bunch
of months even after we all start going
back to work and by the way when we do
go back to work I think there's gonna be
a lot of social distancing I think a lot
of office space is gonna go empty as
people try and continue to work from
home I think that the idiocy of the
government suggests in the facemasks was
a bad idea I think that's gonna go by
the wayside and everybody's gonna be
wearing face masks for at least several
months here now there are some possible
alleviating factors obviously the
possibility the flu that this
coronavirus flu strain gets killed off
during the during the summer that the
heat tends to drive it down but in
populous areas that may not be enough
okay well with that said here are your
updates across the globe on the
coronavirus levels the the death levels
across across the world right now
there are 800 10,000 diagnosed cases
where up to almost 40,000 deaths
globally in the United States we are up
to 160 3788 new cases as of this point
there are almost 21,000 new cases
identified yesterday again we're gonna
see these numbers go up until they start
to go down simply because we are testing
more and by the way just a note to the
media if you are going to suggest that
America is number one in diagnosed cases
on the basis of absolute numbers as
opposed to per capita
then you also have to acknowledge the
president Trump is right when he says we
are also doing the most tests of any
country because he's saying that on an
absolute basis not on the basis of per
capita so you have to pick your standard
either we're gonna measure per capita
we're gonna measure on an absolute basis
one of the two we had 558 new deaths in
the United States yesterday from
coronavirus it's important to put this
in perspective in the United States we
have approximately 1,500 to 2,000 deaths
per day of heart disease and cancer
those are the two leading killers in the
United States heart disease kills about
650,000 people a year in the United
States cancer kills about 600,000 people
a year in the United States so we could
see I mean the estimates suggest that as
we peak that on a daily level there will
be days when chrono virus kills more
people than heart disease and cancer
which is you know a hell of a number we
only hope that those numbers only spike
for a couple of days or that we never
reach those numbers at all but 558 is a
big number Italy of course had 812 death
yesterday Spain is now surpassing Italy
as the center of the crisis they had 913
deaths yesterday even in places that
have locked us down better than Italy
Spain and probably the United States
Germany had a hundred and four deaths
yesterday France had 418 deaths
yesterday it's funny you know for all
the people who say the u.s. is handling
this worse than any other industrialized
country I have yet to see the evidence
for that there are countries that have
handled it better than we have no
question right South Korea handled it
better than we did perhaps the
Netherlands did but you're comparing
apples and oranges in some of these
cases because when I when I interviewed
dr. deborah birx over the weekend dr.
Burks pointed out with regard to for
example Sweden that not a lot of people
traveling from Wuhan go to Sweden in the
middle of the winter where it gets dark
at 2:30 in the afternoon so that's a
very different thing from the United
States well of course you have
tremendous travel huge population a lot
of diversity that is going to change the
math of fair bet so comparing apples to
oranges is a bad idea
but even Germany which had supposedly
lock this thing down so on increase of
almost 4,500 cases yesterday in 104
deaths France had 400 had about 4000
diagnosed cases in 418 deaths Iran is
lying about their numbers the UK which
recently went into lockdown they had
about 2600 new cases and a hundred and
eighty new deaths on a on a per capita
basis deaths per 1 million population
the United States is still ranking near
the bottom of the rankings
in terms of death per 1 million
population now that is because we're
still at the beginning of this curve
we're not gonna look like these numbers
by the time this is over because the
numbers can only increase from here
deaths are an absolute number of
populations an absolute number and so as
the deaths increase the proportion is
going to is going to increase as well
right now the United States in terms of
deaths per 1 million population we stand
at 9 that's as opposed to Italy Italy
has a hundred and ninety two deaths from
coronavirus per 1 million of the
population so like we are an order of
magnitude times two right now two orders
of magnitude but in order of magnitude
then multiply that by two away from
Italy's standing right now same sort of
deal with Spain Germany well we're
basically on par with Germany at this
point Germany has about as many deaths
per 1 million in the population as we do
France is really way more deaths per 1
million the population and and then the
UK has more deaths per million of the
population again these are places with
smaller populations the the places that
seem to have locked it down pretty well
with small populations Israel has locked
it down pretty well with a small
population Canada has locked it down
pretty well so far with a fairly small
population but Sweden has more deaths
per 1 million the population than we do
so for all the people saying the United
States is doing an awful terrible no
good very bad job with this but there
are things that we could do better but
let's not pretend that we are up there
with Italy in Spain yet because we just
are not that it's not where the facts
lie we're gonna get to more of this
analysis in just one second more facts
more news and the media I think there's
a comfort right now to people
reverting to partisan Pryor's it makes
you feel like the world is half normal
when you can just go on Twitter and rail
at people about stupid crap but the
reality is the world is not normal and
we need to put some of this nonsense
aside for just like 5 seconds would be
really nice cuz frankly I'm tired of it
you're tired of it I was tired of it
before all this happened I think you
were tired of it before all this stuff
happened the fighting over stupid
garbage every single day I'm really
tired of it when you know I have to
worry about the health of my children my
parents and I think that most people
feel the same way and the media
definitely exacerbate that President
Trump doesn't bring the temperature now
with the media definitely exacerbate
that we'll show you how in just a few
minutes first let's talk about the
reality of the situation which is it's
very nice to know who's stepping on your
property at this point right we're all
kind of paranoid about who's gonna step
seven on our property when someone rings
the doorbell you want to know who that
is this is why you should have ring calm
and in cities
across the nation there are their mayors
who've been releasing people from local
jails crime rates are undoubtedly going
to go up as we're gonna discuss in a
little while here ring.com keeps you
safe and secure at your place ring gives
you protection at every corner it helps
you create custom affordable security
for your home ring detects motion when
people come onto your property rings
video doorbells let you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime from
anywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivering or a
surprise visitor you'll get an alert
you'll be able to see here speak to them
all from your phone again we use ring
we've been using ring at our property
for a very long time and for good reason
because we're always worried about
security and it is a good thing to have
ring on the property making sure that my
family is safe get a special offer on
the ring welcome get when you go to ring
calm / been the welcome can includes the
ring video doorbell - and chime Pro it's
all you need to start building custom
security for your home today just go to
ring comm / band that is ring.com / Ben
go check them out right now ring calm /
Ben okay so there is a piece of quasi
good news although not as good as you
would want it to be there's a new study
that was published in The Lancet
Infectious Diseases Medical Journal
yesterday and it estimates the death
rate of coroner virus is significantly
lower than previously reported now
originally the w-h-o director general
Ted Rose autónoma de Asis said the
estimated mortality rate of Kovan 19
globally was about three point four
percent dr. Anthony foutch II had
suggested that it might be anywhere from
one for one to two percent based on
initial reports out of other countries
he said that in the first week of March
but we are now seeing a report from
Lancet estimating that the one percent
fatality rate is probably too high a
more accurate estimation of the percent
of people who will die from
complications from the virus according
to researchers is about point six six
now before we all start getting excited
point six six is still six times
deadlier almost seven times deadlier
than the average seasonal flu CNN
explains when undetected infections
aren't taken into account the Lancet
study found the coronavirus death rate
was one point three eight percent which
is more consistent with earlier reports
but again one of the big problems here
when you're calculating the fatality
rate is the denominator and as we now
know a lot of people are lying about the
denominator in in these particular cases
we don't know how many on symptomatic
cases there are out there the estimate
have been anywhere from for every person
who hasn't
five to ten people may not have symptoms
we have no idea how transmissible it is
because there's a new report today
suggesting this thing may be passable
through air again take all these sort of
new reports of the grain of salt because
we just don't know that hasn't been
confirmed yet okay with all of that said
the lockdowns have now become policy
across the United States we are seeing
three-quarters of the American
population locked in place for the most
part according to the New York Times we
are seeing out of every four Americans
three have restrictions on movement at
this point which is a lot of Americans
locked in place and I'm not gonna be the
person who says that it's time to go out
and party it up because that is not what
the models are suggesting according to
the New York Times the American public
on Tuesday is expected to get its first
look at the statistical models guiding
the policy decisions that have led
governors and mayor's across the country
to order more than two hundred and fifty
million people to stay at home dr.
deborah birx tried to brace both
President Trump and the country for some
tough weeks ahead yesterday she said
even if all the social distancing
guidelines are followed perfectly the
death toll in the nation could reach
100,000 to 200,000 now that would be she
says best-case scenario have you got
twice on the low end out about twice
what we lose every year from the
seasonal flu as I say we lose about
650,000 people a year from heart disease
in the United States another 600,000
people from cancer they'll be really
dangerous the problem is that if we
release everybody into the wild the
theory goes it's not gonna be a hundred
or two thousand two hundred thousand
dead it could be a million dead right
which would easily make this the leading
cause of death in the United States and
it would keep recurring year after until
there is some sort of vaccination or
herd immunity nations across Europe have
continued to see the steady rise in new
infections and death in the United
States the outbreak in New York remains
the largest in the nation more than
1,200 deaths weeks away from its apex
according to Governor Andrew Cuomo more
than 250 coronavirus patients died
between Sunday and Monday the governor
said that number could ultimately reach
800 today in New York alone in Michigan
state officials reported 50 additional
deaths on Monday Governor John bel
Edwards of Louisiana said his state is
already a few weeks behind New York one
of the reasons why you know we gotta
wait this thing out is because for every
day that people don't abide by the
restrictions that's another day when on
the other end you're gonna have to abide
by their restrictions because eventually
we're all gonna be in lockdown until
this thing passes given the the
possibility of massive carnage across
the United States so that is where
things
stand over in Virginia Governor Ralph
Northam has declared that people should
stay in place up until June he says all
the way until June remember it is it is
not even April yet right April is
tomorrow now the the updated order
allows for people to leave their homes
if they have to go out for food supplies
medical care or to get fresh air or
exercise it also allows people to travel
to work places of worship childcare
providers and for volunteer and
caretaking and to seek social services
so the order is not quite as restrictive
as people are making it out to be it's
not like the full-on
stay in place order that is in place in
New York City a lot of businesses are
still open in Virginia and this is
basically the rule the more restrictive
the rule the less amount of time you can
you can keep people in place because in
the end you cannot keep people in place
indefinitely especially as the economy
goes down the tubes and as we're gonna
see there's some pretty significant
ramifications to the economy going down
the tubes now last week if you mentioned
this this is very bad you weren't
supposed to talk about this because this
was undermining the work of trying to
get people to stay at home but if you
look over at Italy it is pretty obvious
that people cannot stay indoors
indefinitely Italy is now risking the
possibility of riots according to
Bloomberg as Prime Minister Giuseppe
Conte fights to hold the telling in
society together through a crippling
nationwide lockdown that a press South
is turning into a powder keg police have
been deployed on the streets of Sicily's
capital palermo amid reports that gangs
are using social media to plot attacks
on stores a bankrupt ferry company
halted service to Palermo including
vital supplies of food and medicine as
the state creaks under the strain of the
corona virus pandemic officials worried
the Mafia may be preparing to step in
now Italy has always been a place with a
thriving black market estimates suggest
that perhaps half of Italy's economy
thanks to high tax rates and low ability
to govern is in the black market so it
is not a great shock that the breakdown
of the system has caused the criminal
syndicates to step in but with that said
the longer you see states locking down
the more that strain there's gonna be on
supply chains because who exactly is
gonna pay for the groceries who's gonna
make sure people keep going back to work
it's gonna be it's going to normally the
market does all of those things but when
the market has been forcibly suspended
by governments what you start to see is
people saying okay I'm not gonna do this
anymore look what happens if the food
doesn't get delivered on time what
happens if the rent check doesn't come
on time right we're gonna start to see
that sort of unrest in the United States
- if this thing goes on long enough so
that's why it's an impaired
that we all locked down like do it right
now lower that curve ramped up
production as fast as possible and
hopefully we can all start getting this
economy moving again
to forestall the kind of activity we are
seeing in Italy hopefully we can do all
of that faster rather than slower so
that we can not see riots in the streets
and violence in the streets the way that
Italy is apparently going to see pretty
soon you know these are unthinkable
things that we're talking about but they
are not so unthinkable that we shouldn't
be talking about them given the fact
that in the past in the United States
history when we have had depressions
like this there's been significant civil
unrest people tend to forget this about
the Great Depression there was an entire
march on Washington by veterans and that
march on Washington was was utilized by
FDR in the 1932 election as as sort of a
batons wield against Herbert Hoover but
it actually got fairly dangerous I mean
there was serious concern that there was
gonna be like an armed insurrection in
Washington DC in 1932 so there is a you
know this is all stuff that we should be
keeping our eye on and it should be an
impetus for all of us to do what we can
to flatten that curve so we can all get
back to work ASAP the economy actually
matters it's a real thing to real people
we're gonna get into more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that you're staying at home all
day and you may be looking at your walls
and thinking why is my house so ugly
now's a good time to refresh your house
one of the things you may not be
thinking about is your window coverings
it may turn out that your window
coverings really lack certain savoir
faire you really need better window
coverings this is why you need blinds
calm and you can't go out to a blind
stall right now those things aren't open
instead you should be ordering from
blinds.com
not everyone has the means to do a full
renovation but you can make your house
with a lot better with blinds com window
treatments are a simple project you can
do they really benefit the feel and
style of your home experts actually say
not getting enough Sun it increased
levels of stress hormones in your body
so you should consider light filtering
window treatments and roller shades or
cellular shades to transform your Homans
even more of a sanctuary during these
difficult times if you're nervous about
doing it yourself there really is no
reason to be because blinds calm will
help you through every single step
they've helped millions of homeowners
through the process with free online
design help plus they guarantee the
perfect fit you screw it up they will
fix it for you go to blinds.com see how
you can reimagine the look of your home
today rules and restrictions that may
apply go to blinds comm see how you can
reimagine the look and feel of your home
today we've been doing it in my home and
it really does help a lot go check them
out
lines calming and that's blinds.com okay
so South Florida is going to be locked
down until April 15th according to Ron
De Santis
so we're seeing sort of these different
timelines and again those timelines will
all converge because the data is going
to drive this if it turns out that the
pandemic is still out there and that the
risk of an exponential increase in death
continuing for a long period of time if
that risk continues to be out there then
you're going to see these deadlines
extended to santa's announced on monday
morning those living in southeast
florida should stay home until mid-may
to spread the disease who have mitigate
the spread of kovat 19 but then he
walked that back to April 15th for an
end date to what he called the safer at
home order for millions of residents in
Washington DC they've decided to go even
further over the top marry Mayor Muriel
Bowser is now threatening residents of
Washington DC with 90 days in jail and a
$5,000 fine if you leave your home
during the corona virus outbreak which
is a shocking threat obviously Bowser's
and our message remains the same stay at
home the stay at home order has
exceptions for grocery shopping and work
teams essential outdoor recreation like
running is allowed but can't involve
people outside of a household
you know what the penalties should be
like if you're arrested for going
outside your home I mean this is
basically military lockdown this is you
know that that's over-the-top I mean I
don't right now you're letting criminals
out of prison so I'm confused as to how
you exactly expect to enforce a lockdown
order like this we're just arresting
people on mass on the streets of
Washington DC well in some in some
better news ends in well in some better
news we are we are in fact ramping up
production of the machinery necessary in
order to keep that curve beneath the
available level of medical supply
according my coleus to The Wall Street
Journal when President Trump last week
criticized General Motors is effort to
produce ventilators GM executives were
flabbergasted because they'd already
been begun collaborating with a
ventilator company a couple of weeks
earlier they'd mobilized more than a
thousand employees nearly a hundred auto
suppliers to start making the machines
we won't let it deter us said GM global
manufacturing chief Gerald Johnson every
ventilator is a life from GM's account
since mid-march they have been ramping
up their ability to do
ventilators so the GM contingent has
been shifting over its
action Ford said on Monday it's working
with General Electric to make 50,000
ventilators at one of the automakers
facilities in Michigan
by early July obviously we're lagging on
this sort of stuff but the real problem
here is the disconnect between what
Ventech which is the company that really
designs these things said that it could
produce and what they actually can
produced Ventech had provided a range of
possibilities for monthly production of
ventilators one as high as 20,000 a
month each scenario required a gradual
increase for the GM operation to get up
and running the Trump administration was
under the impression it could move to
full production faster they said they
were going to give us a 40,000 much
needed event Slater's very quickly Trump
said and its Witter Post but they were
not able to do that so that is the so we
are ramping up production
president Trump pointed that out
yesterday some private companies are in
the process of making hundreds of
thousands of ventilators so help is on
the way here's President Trump yesterday
in his in his daily presser so we have
10,000 we kept them for this very
specific purpose it sounds like a lot
but it's not when you think about it but
we're making a lot and when you see
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands being made in a very short
period of time because if you look at
what just so we have now ten companies
at least making the ventilators and we
say go ahead because honestly other
countries really they'll never be able
to do it it's a very complex piece of
equipment it's it's big and expensive
okay so we are ramping up production
that is the good news now the question
is how well is all of this going to work
there's an editorial from The Wall
Street Journal today talking about all
of this they say the good news is that
the fatality forecast that's being put
forward by the administration a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand deaths is
much lower than the 2.2 million the
president suggested as a worst-case that
figure of course comes not courtesy of
the president that figure comes from
Great Britain the Imperial College study
that has been so widely cited estimates
could still shift significantly says the
Wall Street Journal the Murray group
plans to update it tomorrow as more data
flow in from states and other countries
the Murray model is the one that is
coming from University of Washington's
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation the Murray model measures
deaths in terms of population rather
than confirmed cases because testing
varies geographically it's also
extrapolating US fatalities based on
evidence from other hotspots and Wu Han
in China after a government lockdowns
one important point is it took 27 days
after strict social distancing was
employed
Luhan before the daily deaths peaked New
York California other states that took
early action to close non-essential
businesses we're starting week three so
it's still probably another week and a
half before we hit peak minimum data out
of China may not be reliable the Murray
study underlines modeling for US states
based on one completed epidemic at least
for the first wave and many incomplete
epidemics is intrinsically challenging
that may be especially true if China has
been lying about their numbers which is
extraordinarily likely the Murray model
also simulates healthcare utilization in
the states over time
based on other countries experience and
their projected fatalities in the United
States about sixty four thousand more
hospital beds 17,000 ICU beds 19,000
ventilators on average will be needed
nationwide but man will be most acute in
a handful of states according to that
study being cited by the University of
Washington for instance according to The
Wall Street Journal New York will need
an estimated 35,000 more hospital and
7300 ICU beds next week when demand for
care is projected to peak which is a lot
but that's a lot fewer than 55,000 to
110,000 hospital beds in 18,000 at
37,000 ICU beds that public health
officials had said a week ago could be
needed which shows how quickly these
projections can vary and change over
time when the Murray summary says daily
deaths in the mean forecast exceeds
2,300 by the second week of April
well peak demand will occur at the
national level in the second week of
April this does vary by States we may
see some bumps along the way as various
states hit their own peaks so these
statistical models are incredibly
variable it's difficult to make policy
based on them one of the big problems
with them also is that they're basically
unverifiable because if the social
distancing works if we all stay at home
and then the numbers are way lower the
temptation is going to be say is going
to be to say well I guess we did too
much
maybe we shouldn't done that in the
first place and so it's it's sort of
unverifiable in the sense that perhaps
if we didn't do it at all the death
rates would've been exactly the same but
at this point better that we do too much
for cut look we're locked down anyway
better that we all abide by the lock
down at least let the rules work for a
couple of weeks until we see what
exactly this thing looks like now one of
the reasons it's hard to tell whether
this thing is working or not is because
other nations are indeed lying about
their own statistics Mike Pompeo made
this point yesterday Secretary of State
Pompeo he said that there are lots of
nations out there that are withholding
their own data he was on with Sean
Hannity and he says listen we
have to deal with the fact that we have
incomplete data and all of our modeling
is based on this incomplete data present
Trump and I have been committed to
making sure that we had the best date
available when you hear doctors bouchy
and Burks talk about risk talk about
fatalities trying to think about how to
model what they need is data they need
data from Italy they need data from
China they need data from Iran we need
every country to step up and provide
accurate transparent information if we
can't have that if we have
disinformation instead there are more
lives that will be at risk not only
today but in the weeks ahead as we
battle this enormous challenge yeah that
is obviously an eminently true the fact
that China has been lying all along is a
serious serious problem and now we find
out that China does have additional data
they've not been releasing not only if
we like everyone's sort of suspects
they've been lying about their death
statistics like if you think they've had
no deaths for several months over in
China I think you have another think
coming I mean there was information
we've read from Radio Free Asia
yesterday suggesting they may have been
up to 40,000 deaths in Wuhan which had
obviously radically shift all of the
modeling that is happening would look a
lot closer to Italy that it would look
to to South Korea China but with that
said China apparently has been hiding
other statistics as well according to
The Wall Street Journal China that when
they counted their infected population
they excluded infected people with no
symptoms this actually would would lower
the the fatality rate in China so the
original statistics that were being
handed out by the w-h-o we're incredibly
skewed this we already know it turns out
that China meta-major is lying about all
of this
China said that more than 1,500 people
who are infected with the new corona
virus but haven't shown symptoms were
excluded from its national tally of
confirmed cases as questions arise about
its accounting of the infectious disease
that bursts into a worldwide pandemic
according to The Wall Street Journal
public concerns about the risk of
infections by asymptomatic carriers have
grown in recent weeks as China begins to
relax its cordon around Wuhan a city
where the virus was first identified now
if China thinks they're only 1500 people
infected with coronavirus from those
symptoms who were out there that of
course is utterly untrue right we were
measuring that 3.4 percent fatality rate
based on China's confirmed cases versus
the number of people who had died with
the confirmed cases but if they think
they're only 1,500 people who were
measured who were asymptomatic that of
course is absolute nonsense
Chang geo a top Chinese health official
said at a press briefing in Wuhan on
Tuesday that the country would report
the number of infected people who are
not showing symptoms beginning on
Wednesday jang gwang chief
epidemiologist of the chinese Center for
Disease Control and Prevention told the
state news magazine it's okay if they
aren't included in the tally of
confirmed cases the key question is have
those people been put under restriction
scientists do not have a consensus on
the impact of asymptomatic cases Italian
scientists racing almost 6,000
infections around Lombardi for instance
found nasal swabs of the asymptomatic
carriers had similar amounts of virus as
those with symptoms which could make
them contagious according to a pre
publication draft but they said the
small number of asymptomatic cases
turned up in contact tracing may mean
such carriers have played a limited role
in spreading the virus which would mean
that the fatality rate is higher than
originally suspected so bottom line is
we just don't know anything at this
point and also until we have an antibody
test we're not gonna know how many
people had this thing and then got over
this thing we're just not going to know
one of the things that makes this also
extremely difficult is because of lack
of testing and because nobody wants to
go to get tested unless you absolutely
have to get tested there are a lot of
cases of the flu that are out there
that people probably think is
coronavirus and that is not right a
couple of weeks ago my son came down
with a fever and we were all freaked out
about it but he he had a fever it was
like for four days it was a low-grade
fever he wasn't feeling good and we went
in and we got him a test it took them
two weeks to get us the results we
literally just got the results and he
was negative for coronavirus now given
what is out there we thought okay well
there's a possibility that he has corona
virus but he did not have Chrome virus
it's a seasonal thing lots of flu cases
out there right now and this is bouncing
up a lot of the data as we're going to
see New York has started to assess
whether the social distancing measures
are actually lowering the curve one of
the things that are using is temperature
numbers lowering well there's a problem
with that which is temperature numbers
my son popped a fever he didn't have
coronavirus in the first place that's
big confound but it is it is certainly
true as Mike Pompeo says that without
complete information it's gonna be
extraordinarily difficult for us to tell
what the hell is going on and here we
need to point out that the World Health
Organization is a garbage heap they're
just awful at their jobs the World
Health Organization not only did they by
China's lie originally that there was no
human to human transmission not only did
they wildly overwrite the fatality rate
because of Chinese misinformation not
only were the heads of the w-h-o hanging
up on reporters in Hong Kong who were
asking about the Chinese government but
it now turns out that the World Health
Organization has basically become a tool
of Hong Kong the World Health
Organization has done nothing about the
Chinese government apparently reopening
their wet markets they're reopening the
wet markets again it is neither racist
and or culturally insensitive to point
out that eating the freakin bats is a
terrible idea and that these wet markets
have now been responsible for both SARS
and this particular disease and that
frankly you should not be allowing wet
markets which have externalities to be
open in any like it's amazing to me I
will say this it is amazing to me I said
this on an earlier podcast and people
sort of went nuts at least on the
hardcore left who have lost their
complete ever loving minds well if you I
don't understand if you're an animal
rights lover why exactly are you
resisting my call for shutting the wet
markets which are some of the most
brutal vicious places on earth they're
truly awful when you're talking about
the killing of exotic animals for meat
and in many cases they're not killed
there even while they're alive in some
cases I mean it's just like it's
horrific its horrific in in the ultimate
hey it's Stephen Miller not that not the
one from the administration the
columnist Stephen Miller over at over at
Twitter red C's has peace in the
American Spectator talking about this he
says the World Health Organization is
not just standing by and letting this
happen they're even running interference
for China during an interview this
weekend with Hong Kong's RTHK news
doctor Bruce Aylward blanked questions
about Taiwan's membership of the World
Health Organization's haiwan is excluded
from the w-h-o thanks to China who
backed current whu-oh director-general
Tedrow siddhanam at first L word
awkwardly pretended not to hear the
question we played this tape yesterday
and then he abruptly ended the call
shortly after the video called went
viral on Twitter a Lord's name was
scrubbed from the WHL website Taiwan's
foreign minister said the w-h-o should
set politics aside in dealing with the
pandemic but the w-h-o has been nothing
but political throughout the kovat 19
outbreak okay there's gonna have to be
some real changes in how we deal with
international institutions like that
like the like the w8 show in the
aftermath of all of this so with all of
this said is this working well we have
some evidence that it is and we have
some evidence that things are still
gonna get really bad even if it is then
we're gonna get to the economic news
we'll get to all of that in just a
second first you have to go to jail
calm and subscribe but go check us out
right now over there if you haven't had
a chance to hang out with us over at all
access live you're missing out it's a
lot of fun people have been hanging out
with us over there we have like 5,000
different questions yesterday on the
all-access live that I did been doing it
maybe twice a week at 5:00 p.m. Pacific
I've been doing it twice a week at 5:00
p.m. Pacific 8:00 p.m. Eastern but our
other host people like Matt Walsh and
michael knowles and jeremy boring and
andrew Clavin we've all been hanging out
with you at night just so we can get
that sense of community again because
this is a very lonely and difficult time
obviously very scary time and so it's
imperative that we have these sorts of
get-togethers I think people have been
really enjoying them really gonna get a
kick out of them right now all of our
members not just the all-access members
get access to in this pandemic after the
pandemics over then we'll restrict it
probably to all access members but go
get your membership right now you get
all the goodies the show is intended for
the all-access members again during the
national emergency during the pandemic
we've opened it up for all of our
members so check us out over at Daley
wire.com not an expensive proposition if
you're around 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight you can join Michael
Noel's over on all-access live and watch
and play the ukulele and sit around in
his kimono or whatever it is that
Michael does every day I have no idea
what Michael was on I don't know what he
does on a daily basis let alone czar in
the pandemic but you can go check that
out over at Daley we're calm you're
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so there is some good news you know
I tried to give you the good news and
the bad news I wanted to be the fulsome
oversight of the data so that we all
know what's going on because I don't
like alarmism I don't like the we're all
going to die if we step outside kind of
stuff and we should never get the
economy back going and we're all gonna
live in lockdown forever and the
government should take over the entire
economy I don't like that kind of stuff
on the other side I don't like the
whistling past the graveyard everything
is fine all of this is overblown nothing
bad is happening I'm gonna again
the theme of this show until there is
further data is we don't have enough
data you're allowed to say that we don't
have enough data we don't know yet we
don't know yet all we can do is watch
the trend lines in Italy things seem to
have started to flatten out in terms of
new cases being diagnosed the question
is going to be how they release people
back into society how we trans people
back into society do we go through and
find all the people who've already had
it are they the first people to go back
to work as a young healthy people who
are the first to go back to work what
sort of social restrictions are put on
do we have mass and social distancing in
place the the recovery here so let's
let's put this way there's me two stages
to the recovery when it comes to the
economy the first stage to the recovery
is going to be a bit of a u-shaped
recovery a soft launch of the economy
people start and go back to work slowly
in waves as we recover from this and
then after a vaccine is developed this
is gonna be the roaring 20s but the
wrong 2000 twenties right people are
gonna be so it's gonna be like orgies in
the streets people at Giant raves like
people people are gonna lose it because
after being locked down for a year if
you're a 20 year old haven't been locked
down for a year the the notion that you
are going to not go to every party that
is possibly imaginable is just insanity
right I mean that's what's gonna happen
and then the economy will explode cuz
people are gonna spend lots of money
people are gonna want to be creative
people don't want to get gonna want to
get out so let's put this wait do I
think this is forever no I don't think
this is forever
so I think this is bad for I think it's
worst for the next couple of months I
think after that it's unpleasant for a
few months after that and then hopefully
by the early part of next year we have
vaccine in the works and then I think
everything explodes and I think the
economy not only moves forward I think
it moves forward an extraordinary rate
because I think everybody goes back to
work and we're all excited to be out
there I mean it'll feel like the first
day of spring in Boston right
all of this sort of feels like when I
was in law school in Cambridge the
winter was really long it was really
lonely it really sucked all there was to
do is basically hang out your dorm room
and I didn't drink but a lot of my
friends were a lot of alcoholism at
Harvard Law School during the winter and
then first day of spring and by spring I
mean like it's 50 degrees outside first
day of spring everybody is out everybody
wants to be outside everybody wants it
that's what it's gonna be like on the
other end of this so let's keep that in
mind there is a light at the end of the
tunnel here the good news is that
apparently the restrictions are slowing
corona virus infections according to new
data the New York Times has harsh
measures including stay at home orders
and restaurant closures are contributing
to rapid drops in the number of fevers a
signal symptom of the most of most
corona virus infections recorded in
states across the country according to
intriguing new data produced by a
medical technology firm at least 248
millions and million Americans and at
least 29 states have been told to stay
at home and it seemed nearly impossible
for public health officials to know how
effective this measure and others have
been in slowing coronavirus but the new
data offer evidence in real-time that
tight social distancing restrictions may
be working potentially reducing hospital
overcrowding and lowering in death rates
according to the experts the company
cans a Health produced a national map of
fever levels on March 22nd was able to
spot the trend within a day since then
data from the health departments of New
York State in Washington State have
buttress the finding making it clear
that social distancing has saved lives
and this became obvious because
President Trump extended the until the
end of April his recommendation that
Americans stay in lockdown Kenza has
more than 1 million thermometers in
circulation they'd be getting up to
162,000 daily temperature readings
since kovin 19 began spreading in the
country the company normally uses that
data to track the spread of influenza so
identify clusters of coronavirus
infection kins a recently adapted
software to detect spikes of atypical
fever that don't correlate with
historical flu patterns as of noon
Wednesday the companies live maps from
fevers holding steady or dropping almost
universally across the country with two
prominent exceptions one was in an area
of New Mexico where the governor only
issued stay at home orders the day
before and also in adjacent counties in
southern Colorado the other was a ring
of Louisiana parishes surrounding New
Orleans but a hundred and 150 miles away
from it and that was possibly caused by
the outward local spread of infections
from New Orleans which was set off by
crowding during Mardi Gras so some
information this thing is starting to be
empty I mean well Bob walked
who is one of the chief he's the chair
of ucf at ucsf menthe medicine over over
Berkeley he said yesterday that there is
no change in the hospital's status at
UCSF and he says that our command center
briefings now seem less newsie like
we're over prepped for a surge that may
not be coming which will be great
he says the overall case is still mild
growth in San Francisco everyone is
struggling with the curve is flat versus
calm before the storm narratives but
even pessimists are starting to tilt
toward the former so maybe these
lockdown measures are working we also
discussed yesterday the fact that
coronavirus slowdowns in Seattle suggest
that restrictions are working now in New
York which is ground zero for all of
this it's where the most people are it's
where people are living in
extraordinarily close quarters things
are getting bad over there
how bad remains to be seen there's an
article in The Wall Street Journal today
talking about NYU Langone telling ER
doctors to think more critically about
who gets ventilators which of course is
the sort of rationing that we've seen in
Italy which is so frightening and while
you leg on health one of the nation's
top academic medical centers told
emergency room doctors they have sole
discretion to place patients on
ventilators and institutional backing to
withhold futile intubations so they're
not going to force people to put people
on ventilators if they believe that that
is going to be a complete waste of time
a March 20th email from Robert V Mia who
heads the New York health centerís
department of emergency medicine
underscored the life or death decisions
placed on the shoulders of bedside
physicians as they treat increasing
numbers of coronavirus patients with a
limited supply of ventilators New York
state guidelines established in 2015
recommend that hospitals appoint a
triage officer or committee to decide
who gets events later when rationing is
necessary the guidelines say that
removing the decision from the physician
treating the patient avoids conflict of
interest allows an officer or committee
with access to overall ventilator
availability to make the call prevents
health worker burnout and stress but dr.
phinius says we just don't have time to
do all of this stuff in emergency
medicine we don't have the luxury of
time data or committees to help with our
critical triage decisions he wrote
senior hospital leadership recognizes
this and supports us to use our best
clinical judgment fee Mia wrote that
decisions about airway management and
whether to use events later or other
respiratory support devices or at the
sole discretion of treating physicians
he told doctors to think more critically
about whom we intubate that of course is
scary scary stuff now with that said
Andrew Cuomo governor of New York he
says that the rate of doubling is
already down we are both things can be
true right it can be that we end up in a
very bad medical situation in New York
because there are shortages events
lehder and shortages of ICU beds and
also it can be true that things are
getting better but we're not going to
see the impact of things getting better
particularly in terms of the deaths
which trail the hospitalizations by a
week to two weeks that we may not see
the results of this in the death rates
for another week or two here is Andrew
Carmel yesterday saying that the rate of
doubling is already down in New York
thanks to the measures being taken the
number goes up the number goes down
there's no doubt that the number is
still increasing there's also no doubt
that the rate has slowed we had a
doubling of cases every two days then
doubling every three days than a
doubling every four days then every five
we now have a doubling of cases every
six days so while the overall numbers
going up the rate of doubling is
actually down so Chris Cuomo by the way
in breaking news has come down with
coronavirus as well so prominent people
are not escaping coronavirus they're
just able to get tests more quickly
although at this point testing has been
radically increased you know look it's
it's scary out there Andrew Cuomo
yesterday he basically was pleading for
health care workers to come out again I
can't say it enough the people who are
going out in the midst of this epidemic
this pandemic and are risking their life
seriously risking their lives take care
of people those are those are the the
people storming the beaches in Normandy
I mean this is this is heroism if you're
watching the the respiratory therapists
the nurses the the doctors the people
who are on the frontlines of this thing
going out and doing this thing nothing
but admiration for those people they
honestly congressional medals of Honor
for all of them when this is over like
mass Congressional Medal of Honor
because it's it's you're putting your
life at risk doing this sort of thing I
mean we've seen reports from other
countries the 25% of health care workers
are coming down with this because you're
in close proximity with people who have
this incredibly transmissible virus here
is Andrew Cuomo pleading for health care
workers yesterday by the way about
80,000 people in New York State have
responded which is just incredible I
mean what a country this is here is
Andrew Cuomo as governor of New York I
am asking healthcare professionals
across the country if you don't have
healthcare crisis in your community
please come help us in New York now we
need relief we need relief for nurses
who are working 12-hour shifts one after
the other after the other we need relief
for doctors we need relief for
attendants so if you're not busy
come help us please and we will return
the favor
so that calls had not gone unheeded you
know and health care workers have been
stepping forward now obviously there's
an enormous amount of economic fallout
from all of this as well the the
estimates from the Federal Reserve is
that coronavirus job losses could total
47 million
47 million which is just an insane
number the Fed estimates unemployment
rate may hit 32 percent now again we can
all hope and pray this is short-term it
will be short-term because we're not all
gonna remain in lockdown forever but 32
percent unemployment mean those are
those are levels that not even the Great
Depression raged I mean these are these
are insane levels of unemployment of
course that was caused by bad government
action
you know bad government policy this is
being caused by the forcible lockdown of
the entire global economy which will be
alleviated as coronavirus itself wanes
but I mean these are nightmare scenario
numbers the projections are much worse
than st. Louis Fed President James
Bullards much publicized estimate of 30
percent according to CNBC they reflect
the high nature of at risk jobs that
ultimately could be lost due to a
government induced economic freeze aimed
at halting the corona virus spread st.
Louis Fed economist at Miguel Faria
Castro wrote these are very large
numbers by historical standards this is
a rather unique shock unlike any other
experienced by the US economy in the
last 100 years now this does not account
for workers who may drop out of the
labor force which brings down the
headline unemployment rate they do not
estimate the impact of recently passed
government stimulus which will extend
unemployment benefits and subsidize
companies for not cutting staff but we
are estimating that by the end of the
week another almost 3 million people
will join the unemployment lines now
people are going to receive unemployment
that was in the new trillion-dollar
stimulus bill people are gonna be
receiving unemployment that basically
amounts to obviously the the twelve
hundred dollar check per month but
they're also gonna be receiving
unemployment benefits that fill
and most of what people were making is
is what was in that bill when you file
for unemployment for the next four
months
most people are noting receiving a check
until mid April so April to May May to
June June July July to August so you
could be receiving checks up through
August according to current estimates
hopefully the goal is by the time we get
to June and July people are starting to
hire back we are seeing massive
furloughs over at Macy's and gap now we
hear the daily where we're trying to
make sure that everybody stays employed
everybody in every company is working to
make sure they don't have to layoff
workers may see gap other retailers are
furlough in tens of thousands of
employees beginning this week the
furloughs he adds the swelling ranks of
the unemployed and the economic damage
resulting from coronavirus which is now
infected more than a hundred fifty
thousand people according to The Wall
Street Journal the federal rescue
package provides direct payments to
individuals enhanced unemployment
benefits and loans for small employers
that keep people on their payrolls
Macy's closed its doors March 17th
Macy's employs roughly 125 thousand
people they said the majority of those
employees will be furloughed they'll
still have access to the company health
benefits gap is doing the same thing
there furloughing 80,000 people they
never seen a furlong and a firing is the
assumption is that at a certain point
the retail shops will open back up and
those people will come back on the job
so it's not a full on firing in the
midst of all of this there is some talk
of economic turmoil and that that is
going to that is going to be exacerbated
by the length of this thing this is one
of the reasons it's not in a matter of
small priority to ensure that the
economy gets back on track it as a
matter of top priority make sure that we
don't have an epidemic that kills a
couple million people but the economy is
definitely a priority here it must be a
priority because we're already starting
to see signs that this is going to be
unworkable and faster than we thought it
was going to be the president from
yesterday said that the economy comes
second saving lives of course this is
true here as president robbed yesterday
it's so bad for the economy but the
economy is number two on my list first I
want to save a lot of lives we're gonna
get the economy back I think the economy
is going to come back very fast Steve's
just asking about the economy what's it
like
we basically shut down our country and
we did that in order to keep people
separated keep people apart they're not
working in offices that not in airplanes
together you know we really shut it down
yeah well again those priorities are in
order but let's not pretend they're not
downside costs - every day that we are
out of work I'll give you an example the
Whole Foods employees are now staging a
nationwide sick ad so right now there
are literally millions of people who are
dependent on Whole Foods why because the
Amazon fresh is Whole Foods right Amazon
owns Whole Foods
so when Whole Foods workers storm out
it's not just you you're losing your
organic kale
you're losing your ability to actually
obtain many of the supplies that you
need if you're an older person and
you're ordering stuff online to be left
at your door you could be utterly
screwed by this and this I'm sorry but
this is not a time for you to strike for
a better pay this is not a time for you
to strike for a better pay because in a
normal economy you know what the company
would do they would just fire all y'all
and they would just hire all the people
who are newly unemployed that's exactly
what gone on in normal time this is not
a normal time hey by the way this is not
a conservative versus liberal thing okay
back in the nineteen nineteen fifties
there's a point where where President
Harry Truman Truman tried to nationalize
the steel industry because of striking
workers okay the fact is that striking
in a time of pandemic not because of bad
work or pay but because you just want
more money
I'm sorry everyone else lost their job
everyone else lost their damn job okay
like if I were Amazon and I had the
capacity I'd fire everybody who strikes
right now and I bring in workers who are
willing to work I would because this is
it's unconscionable the reason I say
it's unconscionable is not only are you
depriving people of the supply lines
that are keeping the country running
right now not only that but Amazon
offered you additional benefits already
this is not your striking because
Amazon's forcing you to go to work on
March 31st today hopefuls employees are
gonna call in sick to the man paid leave
for all workers who stay home or so of
self quarantine during the crisis free
coronavirus testing for all employees
hazard pay here's the big one hazard pay
of double the current hourly wage for
employees who show up to work during the
pandemic you mine are paid doubled just
for showing up to work well everyone
else in the country is out of work I'm
sorry no no okay and by the way the
actual the actual thing that Whole Foods
has done Whole Foods
buried in this article from vice has
increased hourly pay for its workers
already by two dollars an hour in the
midst of all this they've offered to
provide two weeks of paid sick
two workers who test positive for kovin
19 and said it would not penalize
workers for calling out sick so already
saying we're not gonna penalize you
we're not gonna fire you if you call out
sick but you need to go get a test
because we don't just want people
staying home without getting a test
which is perfectly reasonable because
you need the supply chains working a
Whole Foods worker in Chicago organizer
of the sick-out who wish to remain
anonymous because they feared
retaliation they should you should be
fired outright
the most obvious demand we have is for
an increase in hazard pay we're asking
for double pay double pay since we first
announced the intents into a sick-out
Whole Foods announced a temporary raise
of $2 an hour which isn't enough okay
I'm sorry what happens if all the cops
call out sex they want double pay what
happens if all of the medical
professionals call out sick because they
want double pay you want to it's funny
everybody is happy to talk about people
in the speculative market buying up
coronavirus masks and then trying to
sell them for a thousand dollars on eBay
this is the same damn thing you're
asking for double pay in the midst of a
pandemic because you know that those
employees are necessary in order to make
sure that the old people get their food
okay that person should be fired
outright fire it out right and then
there's talk I mean things are gonna get
ugly
then there's talk about rent strikes cuz
people are talking about not just not
paying their rent which has been
alleviated right I mean people are not
like people are already saying that
we're going to basically delay your rent
they go rent later which is perfectly
reasonable because the property owner is
saying they're extending a zero interest
loan effectively right they're saying
we're not going to evict you there are
no eviction orders that are already in
place across the country some tenants
are vowing to go on a rent strike until
the corona virus pandemic subsides
meaning they don't want to pay the rent
ever for the pleasure of living in their
house okay this is like saying that you
should get free food from the grocery
store for the next three for the next
three months that's not the way this
works okay we can float you a check to
cover your rent but people do need to
get paid for your use of their resources
okay and as things get worse here as
this goes on there's gonna be more and
more demand that you just get stuff for
free that you not actually have to pay
stuff on the other end again no one
should be evicted during this thing you
lost your job the government said you
had to lose your job you lost your
income stream because the government
said you had to lose your income stream
but that does not mean that on the back
end you shouldn't have to pay for the
resources that you are using right now
or that the government shouldn't be
filling that in right now you want to
make sure that nobody's ever able to
rent an apartment again definitely go
forward with the rent
right you wanna make sure that no new
development has ever had in the country
make sure you go forward with a rent
strike and you have nationalization of
housing strike advocates aren't saying
that tenants can't pay rent if they
can't earn a living let's cancel rent
for 90 days cancel and not again I'm not
saying that you should have to sign a
check for your rent nobody's getting
evicted right now I'm saying on the back
end of course you should be charged for
rent you are using the resource are you
not this is like saying that we should
force everybody to go to work without
getting paid for the next 90 days
because of the pandemic use of resources
cost money things are gonna get so ugly
they're gonna it's so ugly if this
continues for a long period of time
truly ugly right now I mean you should
there was a pictures yesterday over at
this Pennsylvania Food Bank and I mean
just unbelievable pictures of cars
waiting in line dispense Ivania Food
Bank because people don't have jobs
because they don't have money right now
that money should come in we hope the
other federal government over the next
two three weeks but I mean just
astonishing astonishing pictures of
thousands of people in line waiting to
get canned goods goods from a food bank
this is stuff I never thought I would
see in America and it better alleviate
as fast as possible or things are gonna
get supremely
supremely ugly okay well time for a
quick thing that I like and then a thing
that I hate so things that I like
everybody's been watching Tiger King I
started watching Tiger King on Netflix
last night with the wife because it was
recommended by Colton among others and
if this is the average voter in America
then yeah I'm gonna go with Aristotle's
dictatorship of the wise if this is the
average voter in America it isn't
obviously Tiger king is the story of
crazy people who like hanging out with
Tigers and they are indeed crazy here's
a little bit of a trailer
they have a harder than the soul and a
mind I've learned from them but Carroll
blasek and Kate say I can't have that
you tiger if he ever had an Anna man in
his life it was Carroll bastard yo you
cool cats and kittens it's Carolyn Big
Cat Rescue Carol is the mother Teresa of
cats we will in the private possession
of these cats this is my way of living
and nobody's gonna tell me any otherwise
has an army of people working in the
world so that that's the entire series
the entire series is what in the world
is this seriously that's the entire
series so if you're just looking for a
good old American craziness then this is
what you are looking for other utter
craziness okay time for that I hate
alright so as I've been saying you know
we live in a time where we should be
able to come to some bipartisan
consensus we are not in fact because
people feel a certain level of comfort
in being angry at the other side and so
you end up with idiocy like this so
yesterday the President of the United
States had at the White House the my
pillow guy right the guy who makes my
pillow which is a great product right
and he happens to be a fantastic story
as well his name is Mike Lindo and
Michael and Zell's backstory is really
pretty amazing I mean the guy was
essentially I think a drug addict and he
made a comeback by becoming a religious
Christian and now he's got tens of
thousands of people working for him
making pillows on demand for people
pillows that that people are able to
customize and so he is now converted his
factories over to making masks his
company has been shifting production to
n95 masks they're gonna start making
50,000 and 95 masks a day starting this
Friday says we've dedicated a night 75%
of my manufacturing to produce cotton
face masks which is an amazing amazing
thing okay so he gets up at the White
House and Trump gives him the podium and
here's what he has to say Thank You mr.
president for your call to action when
which has empowered companies like my
pillow to help our nation win this
invisible war now I wrote something off
the cuff if I commit this God gave us
grace on November 8 2016 to change the
course we were on God had been taken out
of our schools and lives a nation had
turned his back on God and I encourage
you use this time at home to get them to
get back in the word read our Bibles and
spend time with our families okay
the median lost in mines because because
here he was praising Trump and invoking
God and suggesting that God wanted Trump
to be present and all that man's
entitled to his beliefs okay but this is
so the media lose it they lose it so
they're members of the media who are
suggesting and this is a violation of
church and state it is not in fact a
violation of church and state for the
effort for this guy to talk about God
from the podium
yeah idiots and people were like why is
he even there why is he even there
seriously
Ram RAM kapal from CNN he tweeted out
he's the executive editor of CNN he said
in case you were wondering what my
pillow is doing in a time of coronavirus
they're developing 50,000
face masks today what are you doing in a
time of corn of virus you douche bag
like seriously what are you doing being
over at CNN and whining about crap like
what what are you doing how many how
many face masks you providing okay you
would you do the same thing CNN guy that
I do for a living the difference is I'm
not gonna look anybody in the in the
face and yell at them for getting a
White House credit line after developing
after devoting their entire production
resources to developing the medical
resources we need like how how much what
douche bag do you have to be for your
priority be why is that guy even
speaking at the White House he's being
nice to Trump was even there cuz he
develops face masks what do you do for a
living aside from write crap Chiron's
over at CNN Ali Velshi over at MSNBC he
did the same thing Trey says Trump just
called the my pillow guy up to the
podium in the Rose Garden you cannot
make this stuff up
what are you doing Ali Velshi over at
CNBC MSNBC look what how many face masks
you in the back room over there with
your sewing machine are you making those
face masks in the back room putting
together friends ablators Newsweek
columnist Seth Abramson who's just the
worst he tweeted out deer trumpets this
is why media doesn't want to cover your
god Emperor's coronavirus rallies
because the GD my pillow CEO was holding
forth on the
turn on a day that 500 Americans died
and 20,000 got sick from the virus the
briefing was intended to focus on um and
what what have you been doing Seth
Abramson Scott's workin he's deputy
director of the 2009 Presidential
Inaugural committee and 2012 DNC s and
now Trump is having my pillow guy speak
this is absurd hashtag stopped airing
Trump joy Reid of MSNBC when she's not
busy writing homophobic post that she
pretended somebody else wrote wrote not
a prank okay perfect everything is fine
over the Sam Stein of The Daily Beast
I'm a proponent of TV carrying Trump's
presser but allowing corporations to use
them as advertising platforms seems like
the exact opposite of news how are you
this blind how are you this blind that
your top priority is how dare this guy
mentioned God and praised Trump he's
developing tens of thousands of masks
that's the priority you do like
seriously what the hell is wrong with
you people what the hell is wrong with
you people
you say why won't your entire priorities
Trump is not getting the medical
resources to the people on time this guy
is going out of his way to convert his
entire factories to produce medical
resources and your chief takeaway is
he's he's being nice to Trump so he's a
bad man he's bad bad man
meanwhile members of the media continue
to stump for Trump suppressors to be
canceled on TV because very bad that
Trump should be like look your
fact-checking him we all know it I mean
what first of all the worst thing that
could happen for members of the media is
for Trump's oppressors to start to stop
being aired what would they do the rest
of the day actually report on the news
they instead they wouldn't be able to
fulminate and pretend righteous
indignation Don Lemon last night over
NCN he's like why are we even taking
Trump's pressors well because a lot of
newsworthy stuff is happening at the
Trump pressors hey dr. Burks is speaking
there dr. foul shoo speaking there and
yes it's newsworthy when a self-made
millionaire in the united states with
tens of thousands of employees converts
his dozens of factories over to making
masks that happens to be a newsworthy
thing even if you don't like the fact
that he's a religious christian who
likes Trump you idiots here's Don Lemon
on CNN making a fool of himself I'm not
actually sure if you want to be honest
that we should carry that live I think
we should run snippets I think we should
do it afterwards and get the pertinent
points to the American people because
he's never ever going to tell you the
truth it's obvious it's transparent to
me this has become
those press briefings have become his
new apprentice they become his new
rallies and he treats the press and the
media as if he's talking to the people
in his rallies it's the same thing it's
no different is that the audience is not
there okay you just don't like that he's
president I get it I get that you hate
Trump and you hate that he's president
you don't like how he talks and all of
that I have some problems how he talks
to guess what he's the presidents of the
United States you know who I didn't like
how he talked also in a different way
Barak Obama who's just much more subtle
at telling lies in South glorying right
Trump is just a blunt version of Obama
he just he passed himself on the back
physically like during during press
conferences he actually grows a third
arm to Pat himself on the back and talks
up his own achievements and engages it
in the sort of fluffing that you see in
in real estate all the time they sort of
puffery that you see in real estate all
the time okay I get that you hate that
he's also the president and his
newsworthy what he says and if it's not
newsworthy then stop covering them all
together idiots okay and then Chris
Hayes does the same thing over on MSNBC
why are we even taking Trump's pressors
he's the President of the United States
why do I have to explain this to you
it's more interesting to hear what
former Obama his staffers have to say on
MSNBC Chris Hayes I think it's pretty
harrowing for all of us to watch this
lack of leadership from the White House
and to frankly watch a lot of the media
go along with it because his press
conferences as always are still
entertaining in part because he is
competitive in part because he does lie
and you can catch him in those lies and
hold him accountable but that doesn't
make for an effective public health
response yeah that's why he's bragging
about the ratings it's obviously above
my pay grade I don't make the call but
we take them or not but it seems crazy
to me that everyone's still taking them
when you got the my pillow guy getting
up there talking about reading the Bible
again like this is your priority okay
you wonder why people don't trust the
media this is why people don't trust the
media tell us why people don't mind when
President Trump slams idiots like Jim
Acosta and ladies find you somebody who
loves you like Jim Acosta loves Jim
Acosta yesterday at the White House Jim
Acosta gets up and his only question is
what do you say mr. president to people
who are upset at you okay if ever
there's been a loaded question that
question during the Obama era is what do
you say to people who love you
write it but fro for Trumpets what do
you say to people who are upset at you
mr. president every question from Jim
Acosta is like this
what is the information you are
sitting okay I happened to do interviews
a fair a fair bit on this program and on
the radio program on the Sunday special
I interview a lot of people people on
the other side of the aisle - you know
what you tried to do with the question
elicit useful information that is the
purpose of a question I had on pens and
Birks
on Sunday and all I did was ask them
straight questions about pandemic
response about how exactly the
government was going to deal with this
about estimates about numbers in city of
Jim Acosta asking Trump why he's so mean
an orange and Trump rightly slams him
here what do you say to Americans who
are upset with you over the way you
downplayed this crisis over the last
couple of months you know it is going
away and it will go away and we're gonna
have a great victory and it's people
like you and CNN that say things like
that that it's why people just don't
want to listen to CN anymore you could
ask a normal question the statements I
made or I want to keep the country calm
I don't want panic in the country I
could cause panic much better than even
you I could do much I would make you
look like a minor league player but you
know what I don't want to do that I want
to have our country be calm and strong
and fight and win and it will go away
it's almost a miracle and it is the way
it's all come together and instead of
asking a nasty snarky question like that
you should ask a real question and he's
right he should ask a real question but
the media are too busy you know it's so
funny there was that person from oann
who has sort of a fluffy question to
trump and press conference and some some
kind of high school junior high the
media are everyone's an idiot okay rule
of the day everyone's a half the
time as me but lots of people are stupid
okay and one of those somebody slid a
note to this person saying how did your
question help solve coronavirus today
question for Jim Acosta when does your
question ever elicit useful information
ever so when from slams him and says you
could ask a useful question Trump is not
wrong on that you wonder why Trump hates
the members of the media and why they
hate him right back it's that kind of
stuff okay final note on this particular
issue so remember that story a few days
ago that we talked about where a woman
ate fish tank cleaner and then blamed
Trump remember this cuz he's talking
about hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
and phosphate and then she went into her
pantry and she found a fish tank cleaner
that it's called
chloroquine phosphate and she promptly
downed it with her husband and the
entire media was like oh it's because
Trump keeps talking about this stuff
Trump he's talking about this stuff and
that's why that's why this person almost
died her husband did die well um it
turns out this lady also has some
politics to her the Washington free
beacon went through the woman and her
husband's identities and they report
that the woman's most recent donations
in late February to a democratic pack
the 314 Action Fund that bills itself as
the pro-science
resistance and has vocally criticized
the Trump administration's response to
the corona virus pandemic the FEC
records show that Wanda has donated
thousands of dollars to Democratic
electoral groups and candidates over the
past few years including Hillary Clinton
the DCCC and Emily's list her
contributions to Democrats rose sharply
over the past two years her first
recorded political donation was 150
bucks to Hillary Clinton in 2016 the
next year she gave 550 bucks to the DCCC
since 2008 she's contributed
approximately six thousand dollars to
Democratic electoral groups Wanda told
the free beacon we won't make supporters
of Trump but we did see they were using
it in China and stuff and we just made a
horrible tragic mistake it was stupid it
was horrible we never should have done
it it's done now now I've lost my
husband my whole life was my husband we
didn't think it would kill us we thought
if anything it would help us because
that's what been hearing on the news so
the entire media covered this crazy
lady's words as though they were the
words of a deep Trump supporter
disillusioned by President Trump's words
about hydroxychloroquine when in fact
the lady is a longtime Democratic
supporter who doesn't like Trump anyway
and then also happens to be a complete
who down poisonous chemicals and
by the way the media happy to take in to
Joe the Plumber his campaign
contributions back in 2008 don't even
bother to spend five minutes looking
into the person who claims that Trump
killed her husband by recommending a
drug that actively is being used in
addition to as a throw myosin in
hospitals right now for people who are
in desperate need over over in over on
ventilators all right so we'll be back
here with two additional hours later
today make sure you tune into daily wire
all-access tonight become a member so
you can hang out with us I think Knowles
is tonight otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the updates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 the united states has slowed
the spread of coronavirus but there's
one scourge whose virality is only
increasing fake news we will examine the
most egregious examples of how the
left-wing media lies to add panic to the
pandemic then in an effort to combat
kovat a democratic mayor politely asks
criminals to chill and in New York jail
releases a bunch of child molesters
meanwhile prosperity preachers command
the virus to go away and president Trump
rains fire and brimstone down on Jim
Acosta during his latest ratings busting
press briefing check it all out so much
more on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
you